La energía nos rodea,
una cantidad física que sigue
leyes naturales precisas.
Nuestro universo tiene
una cantidad finita de ella;
ni se crea ni se destruye
pero puede tomar
diferentes formas,
tales como energía
cinética o potencial,
con diferentes propiedades
y fórmulas para recordar.
Por ejemplo,
el bombillo LED de 6 vatios
de una lámpara de escritorio
transfiere 6 julios de energía
lumínica por segundo.
Pero saltemos al espacio
para mirar nuestro planeta,
sus sistemas y su flujo de energía.
Los sistemas físicos
de la Tierra incluyen
la atmósfera,
la hidrosfera,
la litosfera,
y la biosfera.
La energía se mueve dentro
y fuera de estos sistemas,
y durante cualquier transferencia
de energía entre ellos,
parte se pierde al entorno,
en forma de calor, luz, sonido,
vibración o movimiento.
La energía de nuestro
planeta proviene de
fuentes internas y externas;
la energía geotérmica de
los isótopos radiactivos
y la energía de rotación
por el giro de la Tierra
son fuentes internas de energía,
mientras que el Sol es
la fuente externa más importante,
que gobierna ciertos sistemas,
como nuestro tiempo y clima.
La luz del sol calienta
la superficie y la atmósfera
en cantidades variables,
y esto causa convección,
produciendo vientos e
influenciando las corrientes oceánicas.
La radiación infrarroja,
que se irradia
desde la superficie
calentada de la Tierra,
queda atrapada por
los gases invernadero
y afecta aún más
el flujo de la energía.
El Sol es también
la principal fuente de energía
para los organismos.
Las plantas, algas y cianobacterias
utilizan la luz solar
para producir materia orgánica
a partir de dióxido
de carbono y agua,
alimentando las cadenas
alimenticias de la biosfera.
Liberamos esta energía alimentaria
utilizando reacciones químicas,
como la combustión y la respiración.
En cada nivel de la cadena alimentaria,
algo de energía se almacena
en las estructuras
químicas recién hechas,
pero la mayor parte
se pierde en el entorno,
en forma de calor,
como el calor de tu cuerpo,
liberado por la digestión
de los alimentos.
Ahora, como los consumidores
primarios se comen las plantas
solo alrededor del
10 % de su energía total
se pasa al siguiente nivel.
Dado que la energía solo
puede fluir en una dirección
en una cadena alimentaria,
desde los productores a
los consumidores y descomponedores,
un organismo que come más abajo
en la cadena alimentaria,
es más eficiente que
uno más arriba.
Así que comerse los productores
es el nivel más eficiente
en la que un animal
puede obtener su energía,
pero sin la aportación
continua de energía
a los productores,
sobre todo de luz solar,
la vida en la Tierra
tal como la conocemos
dejaría de existir.
Nosotros, los humanos, por supuesto,
gastamos nuestra energía
haciendo un montón de cosas,
además de comer.
Viajamos, construimos, usamos energía
en todo tipo de tecnología.
Para hacer todo esto,
utilizamos fuentes como
los combustibles fósiles:
carbón, petróleo y gas natural,
que contienen energía
que las plantas capturaron
de la luz solar
hace mucho tiempo
y que se almacenó
en forma de carbono.
Cuando quemamos combustibles
fósiles en las centrales eléctricas,
liberamos esa energía almacenada
para generar electricidad.
Para generar electricidad,
el calor de la quema
de combustibles fósiles
se utiliza para mover turbinas
que giran imanes,
lo cual, a su vez, crea
campos magnéticos cambiantes
con respecto a una
bobina de alambre,
causando que los electrones sean
inducidos a fluir en el alambre.
La civilización moderna depende
de nuestra capacidad
para mantener la alimentación
de ese flujo de electrones.
Afortunadamente,
no estamos limitados
a la quema de combustibles
fósiles no renovables
para generar electricidad.
Los electrones también
pueden ser inducidos a fluir
por la interacción directa
con las partículas de luz,
que es cómo funciona
una celda solar.
Otras fuentes de
energía renovables,
tales como el viento, el agua,
la energía geotérmica y los biocombustibles
también pueden ser utilizados
para generar electricidad.
La demanda mundial
de energía está aumentando,
pero el planeta tiene
recursos limitados de energía
para acceder a través de una
compleja infraestructura de energía.
Como la población aumenta,
junto con las tasas de
industrialización y desarrollo,
nuestras decisiones energéticas
crecen más y más importantemente.
El acceso a la energía
impacta en la salud, la educación, el poder
político y la situación socioeconómica.
Si queremos mejorar
nuestra eficiencia energética,
podemos utilizar nuestros recursos
naturales de manera más responsable
y mejorar la calidad
de vida para todos.